we won the flame challenge hey crazies
in our first video on black holes we
covered the basics what are they how are
they made what do we measure about them
and I said this they're massive black
balls of death but only if you get too
close and that got me thinking what
would it be like to fall into a black
hole that actually depends on your point
of view and the size of the black hole
first let's revisit a couple things
black holes have two basic parts there's
a singularity where space-time curvature
is infinite and an event horizon where
gravitational time dilation is infinite
the size of that horizon is the size of
the black hole which depends on its mass
more mass makes for a bigger black hole
but still much smaller than you're
probably thinking if you're falling
toward a black hole the first thing you
have to worry about is tidal forces see
the human body can only accelerate so
much before bad things start to happen
we can handle a lot of its short and
temporary falling into a black hole can
be short but it's nowhere near temporary
our limits for continuous exposure are
much lower somewhere between 4 & 6 G's
you pass out somewhere between 10 and 14
G's you just die somewhere between 30
and 40 G's your body gets ripped apart
this is why humans are a major limiting
factor in space travel but it's also an
issue near black holes space time can
get really stretched if I let an
expendable clone fall toward a black
hole then space-time will try to stretch
him too if space time stretches enough
he'll get ripped into a thin piece of
flesh it's called spaghettification and
it's not a good time but we can actually
avoid it if we choose the right black
hole the bigger the black hole the more
gradual to stretch 100,000 solar masses
should be more than enough to keep my
clone conscious all the way in okay so
we've got a supermassive black hole to
work with let's say I'm on my space
station at a safe distance as the clone
approaches the event horizon he
redshifts eventually I have to watch him
from infrared and then microwave and
then radio it into oblivion but I never
see him cross the horizon ever ever ever
ever remember the closer you get to a
source of gravity the slower time goes
it's called gravitational time dilation
the event horizon
a place of infinite time dilation so it
would take an infinite amount of time
for my clone to cross it
but the clone has a very different story
to tell as he approaches the event
horizon he would see my time speed up
but nothing all that interesting happens
for him in an ordinary amount of time he
crosses the horizon and everything goes
black black yeah black inside the event
horizon things get super weird all
space-time paths point toward the
singularity let's learn what is physics
alert almost anything said about black
hole singularities is merely a
hypothesis since there has been no
experimental verification of any kind
many of the details are subject to
possibly significant change in the
future
was that really necessary where was I
again all right toward the singularity
if I'm standing in a grassy field I
could walk this way or that way or even
this way all of which would take me to
different places but if this grassy
field were inside of a black hole no
matter which way I face I'm facing the
singularity of course all the light is
directed that way too so it would just
look black eventually he'll still get
spaghettified but at least now his nerve
signals can't travel to his brain
remember inside the event horizon all
paths point inward including the ones
along his nerves so we can live
guilt-free knowing he won't feel a thing
of course none of the events beyond the
horizon even take place in our universe
so did it even happen what do you think
do the events inside the horizon
actually happen let's continue this
conversation in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to see
more science like this and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy the last video with on
gravitational waves come out response
time Kevin Suarez was amazed that Lego
had gotten switched on just in time to
witness the black hole merger yes that
does seem like we're pretty lucky but
we're actually not with the enhanced
range we actually expected to see
mergers pretty frequently and in the
months between math detection and the
announcements we've already seen several
more links in the doobly-doo Moses asked
about the number of values needed to
describe the curvature of space-time
that actually came from the Riemann
curvature tensor technically it has 256
components in four dimensions
a lot of them are the same there are at
most 20 independent components in that
tensor if the space-time is simple it
could be less but that's super mathy
stuff
speaking of math you stuff math you see
what I did there
Matthew was disappointed I didn't go
into the Matthew details but to be
honest I'm pretty disappointed when I
have to leave some of the Matthew stuff
out it's just tough to convey in a video
without boring people to death or
scaring them away I do have some good
ideas on how I might make it work but
that's gonna take a lot more time and
probably a little help to make a reality
there are things that I just can't do by
myself
nobody's felt like I did Voltron a
disservice by only showing the super
robot you're absolutely right
there's no excuse I stand before you in
shame I'm Pablo you're very welcome to
the credit it's the least I could do
that graphic of the universe is amazing
keep up the great work that's it on
gravitational waves for now maybe this
way of answering comments will stimulate
some conversation thanks for watching